it's not attractive be a lady listen to
this man I feel like I'm learning I'm
learning how to teach hi there reject
nation I'm Greg you speak now I'm Kat
Alvarado
thank you for your four very good very
good mission mat mail person
we're gonna watch a horror film called a
Father's Day it's presented by this
YouTube channel they produce these
amazing horror films like they're there
for shorts that have like a lot of
gravitas to them
gravitas yeah I mean is sound like
non-retention when you see that I'm just
selling you know you're talking about
veritas Wow dad I gotta get to promoting
your things so we can watch this watch
my son watch your podcast put your phone
villains of history these guys do my
podcast listen to it if you want to hear
about real-life villains from the past
listen to cat Alvarado's podcast we talk
about villains killer murders caught
leaders US presidents
I was just on there talked about the
Gainesville Ripper she talked about the
real-life person who inspired the
Amityville Horror the mythology behind
all that and then also she just had
Jamie Kennedy on their head the guy from
Mean Girls on you stop mentioning that
sorry oh I can't say it I mean he's he
disrespected me in public once we're
gonna watch this so now I'm gonna move
on
a Father's Day
I like that font
hey zombies zombie with asthma
[Music]
this little girl
[Music]
that's a good limp
[Music]
that's cool
so different an aversion to zombies
[Music]
it's right at me of my cats interesting
the way the makeup is
was that her dad
[Music]
they're okay with him just like walking
through okay oh he remembers
[Music]
[Music]
hey can I say the B word cuz she's a
[ __ ] that one zombie
so seeing his daughter put him in the
mood it's nostalgic zombie now
you wow that's cool oh cool that one's
also a zombie news
that person must have living hey you
know
so now that's more upsetting to watch
than them eating the other one I feel
weird feeling so sweet but this is
serving at the same
[Laughter]
[Music]
like somehow he doesn't seem old enough
to be her dad which kind of like gives
it a predatory vibe right like he kind
of seems like he's got a young boy she
was holding a head
she's like this is my husband it was my
husband's
she doesn't seem dead enough like why
isn't her makeup the same as his makeup
no she hasn't been obvious long yeah
okay
[Music]
so I guess whoa No
oh [ __ ] is that our bump oh yeah yeah
you do the undead heal
what what did you if they just made out
like Oh your theory was right
I feel like I tainted a really sweet
short film with my predatory I do I
think you did
stuffed animal
that's mom it's really cool that they
get to hang out though even Indy after
being dead
it's so sweet
are we gonna watch them kill a live
person now Oh No
Oh No
[Music]
killer she's a zombie do it
[Music]
[Music]
but you have to protect your child kill
the freaking zombie this is not a
question
[Music]
oh so now he as the dad is gonna charge
them but stance you were taken well I
appreciate everyone's hard work when it
Scrolls
sar for van hier awesome annalee I could
great job
uh-huh fella given some shoutouts II
know I don't know how you felt I'll get
my quick opinions on it I personally
actually really love that I love that
it's a melancholy in a way like a tone
poem of these zombies you know I do
agree that the little girl didn't really
have full-on zombie makeup I think for
this specific tale they're telling I
thought it actually aided with it that
way you can buy a little bit quicker
into the whole thing with
father/daughter dynamic that they had
forming and I like the approach they had
to the zombie lifestyle to is like
they're not just my numbing you know
just completely dead on the inside like
they're still a part of emotion and
senses still that reside within them
even something as little as whether
they're eating that one body at the
beginning and how they do fight like
animals over it like don't get away now
I'm eating this girl with like the fact
that they respond to each other to react
that way and then having them live
through these memories I just thought
was sweet and I actually liked that
weird mixture conflicting emotions oh
absolutely
like I'm disturbed because they're
eating a hand in the flesh and the bone
of the wrist but this is also really
sweet what's happening right now and I
felt really I mean I did get where
you're coming from of like well they're
today they are zombies and there's gonna
eat people why this is such a great
short story and I I agree I think it was
really awesome
I tend to be a person who always finds
like the negative thing I get that from
my mother but that aside I thought it
was amazing I thought it was great for
something to be really good it's got to
make you feel something and this made me
feel all kinds of things it really made
me think and the end really is what put
the cherry on top and put the whole
thing into perspective as far as what I
think the author wanted to portray in
this because it's not about zombies it's
about warfare thinking about when we go
to war with another group of people
those are still people anything that's
ultimately the
message of this short or maybe I'm just
overthinking it I don't think you're
overthinking it the way it's visually
captured reminds me of like specific war
films I've seen where a situation with
the sniper like that unfolds like oh
that's the enemy that are coming on the
lines right now we got to kill them the
mirror image is like when we go to war
and we're killing people even though
they are the enemy there are still
fathers and daughters and families on
the other side they just look different
or have a different set of beliefs yeah
I think it's one of the things that's
Internet's infusing amongst like the all
these like fanatic elements of the Haram
is a nice little bubble package here
like it's called a horror sure but I
really like I think like yeah all the
the horror aesthetic stuff which I love
that they committed to because for
everything they're going with in terms
of being something that's rather sweet I
love that they decided to still commit
to making this like a hard art still
making it very violence like they really
commit to the zombie Gore they commit to
the designs and the designs felt like
classical's especially one of them
looked like a classical zombie from
George Romero the dad I thought that was
neat because it could have easily pg-13
this if they wanted to but the
discipline they committed to all the set
pieces that you would look for in a
zombie film like seeing a group of
zombies just disembowel like that really
set it right on the head for the tone in
the setting right out the gate which is
wonderful I really like the way it made
you feel all these conflicting emotions
because at the end of the day in this
scenario they're zombies freaking kill
but oh now I feel empathy yeah I think
that's why it's important they stuck to
the design aesthetic tutored it to like
of what you'd expect from a zombie
horror film that really allows us to
have a fresh spin on it and I think if
they went pg-13 with it it wouldn't feel
as fresh of a take on it for some rittle
bit of a cop-out it's where it ended
where it wasn't resolved that leaves you
as the viewer with the question mark who
am i rooting for
yeah I couldn't like yeah I was reading
for the live people but they made me
like these zombies yeah this made me
curious about the song the rules of
their zombie world they clearly feel
like they're having these very human
bonding experience on D they're not just
looking for flesh and trying to eat it
yes empathy for her cuz he sees her in
pain
yes exactly I've never seen a zombie
movie that does that that'd be cool to
have like the world the world where you
do have like your humans of course but
then you have if the zombies are not
just one-dimensional they are vampires
already so I guess that's the next level
is have a zombie movie where they're all
like in love and why do you say it
sarcastically
why do you suggest I get it from my
mother it just kind of feels like cliche
like that's a formula now that we see in
TV where it's like let's take fill in
the blank horror genre and make it so
that they're all doing it you know when
you take dolls and you're like oh you
know it works so I'm like oh yeah they
did the vampire thing I do it was on
base they did we robots like mean what
else are you gonna do and then after
they do a zombies they're gonna do it
with mummies oh my gosh look mummies are
in high school
mummies in high school Wow God Hollywood
does not realize how terrible this is
password
thanks altar for presenting who does not
subscribe to altar subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell and
Kat Alvarado make sure to check out our
podcast villains of history as soon as
you can people check out our episode
link in the description box
the
that's why it looks so bright there we
go nice pretty huh
and our softens the light it's upgraded
good good you know to use limited
vocabulary yes